DEVIN LIVI: The greenhouse
actually started in 1935.
It was located on main campus
between Roberts Stadium
and Faculty Road.
So we've had a greenhouse
for quite some time,
and we've been utilizing it.
We've expanded and grown.
We have a number of houses
where it started as one,
but in 1935, the original
one was established.
Anything that you see on
main campus in the gardens
originates here.
Most of the smaller
plant material
will originate
here in some form.
We buy different things--
shrubs, small woody plants.
But primarily, all the annuals
and all of the smaller plants
that you see
originate from here.
JOHN WISNIEWSKI:
Every year, we try
a few different
varieties of plants, just
to see what does
well in Princeton.
We used to try to stick
with orange colors
because they're the Princeton
colors, as more of a highlight.
But some plants
don't come in orange,
so you're forced to use
whatever the plants-- whatever
you can get that way.
But we try a few
things every year.
No one dictates
what we need to use,
so it's a really
great environment
to be able to try
different things.
We have groups that come from
all over during the summer
to tour the gardens,
horticulturalists.
And they'll make comments on
how we use the different plants.
DEVIN LIVI: So I think it's a
great environment for people
who are coming
into the university
to learn about
plants in general,
plant material itself-- annuals,
perennials, woody plants.
We also have a group
of people, volunteers
that come down certain
times throughout the year.
And they prune-- they learn
how to prune the right way, how
to plant the right way.
Most of the men and women
know how to do these things.
But it's always a good
refresher because it's not
something they do every day.
So it's a great way
to learn new things,
to find out from
people that they
don't work with every day, that
work at the grounds department,
and to learn from one another.
And so that's what we
do a lot down here.
We try to use native
plants whenever possible.
So that's some
large trees-- we're
using native trees and
shrubs when possible.
And we've changed
Prospect Garden a bit
throughout history, where it
was a lot more annual plantings.
Now, there's a lot
more perennials.
There's some woody
plants, so it's
more sustainable in the
act of that we're not
having to water as often.
We're not having to
maintain as much.
So really, the
history of the garden
has kind of come along
with the history of campus,
where we're trying to do things
more sustainably than we once
did.